I hired these 10 real police officers to
protect me from 100 assassins if you
keep me alive for the next 30 minutes
I'll give each of you ten thousand
dollars
if at any point I die the Assassins get
the hundred grand server start the start
since the timer's now ticking let's go
let's go let's go let's go
we only have five minutes before the
Assassins are released Sheriff what's
the game plan we're gonna go up to the
observatory and we're gonna hold it down
and protect you this is real money on
the line each of you get 10 000
macaronis if we survive that's a lot of
donuts dude I'm in to the observatory
let's go everyone
uh Sheriff we're here what do we do now
we gotta go up here to the top there's
only a couple of ways in and a couple of
ways out we got The High Ground we hold
the entrances it's gonna be a Kill Zone
oh almost out of time four seconds
let's go let's do this
all right what we're gonna do is go over
the mountain to cut them off while
everyone else goes around
officers there's a hundred assassins on
their way to kill us right now and every
30 seconds my location is pinged on
their Maps so they know exactly where I
am all right everybody secure those two
sides gonna get a couple out here in the
middle all right I got the stairs I got
Center I got said I'm watching the right
side hey I see the first assassins
and because the Assassins are able to
respawn me and the cops got a giant
Health boost all right we got people
rolling in sorry you got them coming
from the East
ow I took damage I lost 50 homes there's
so many I'm just shooting up
I'm starting to think I don't know if
this was the right path how far is it
we have survived six minutes only 24
remaining we got a lot on the left hand
they're at the bottom of these stairs we
gotta get out of here
they're all gonna be distracted up there
go backside around the whole back of the
Dome
would you advise I don't jump down in
the back I would not jump down on the
mac oh all right well too late no no
don't do that all right whoever wants to
help me
oh there's so many what did I do get
behind me I'll take the bullets for you
this is a bad idea fall back fall back
fall back we need to move we need to
move hey I'm going around the back
there's so many following you Jimmy like
actually are you willing to take a
bullet for me Chris I've always been
willing to take a bullet for you server
decoys active I look like an assassin
right now all right lead the way come on
guys let's get him out go go go go go go
I'm getting lit up up here in front oh
my gosh Bob I'm scared I'm scared okay
get it get in the car get in this car
right here right here right here I'm in
go
oh my God
I'm taking bullets for you Jimmy not
enough take more Jimmy this is for you
go
go go
go go go I'm not gonna be in this video
for a long time they're all on me
Chris got eliminated Mr Beast health is
almost halfway bro's a noob
oh my gosh we lost two cops we're going
to the Waypoint oh wait all right let's
go let's go
it's me and you hurry yeah okay get in
get upstairs look at all the rest of the
cops I need you we're on the way we're
at the city hall it's holding it only
two entrances all right we got this we
got this guys let's go assassin you got
the best of us at the first location but
we are way more fortified now bring it
on it looks like he's at the bank the
bank he's at Pacific Bank all right come
on guys we got this I need that money
for taxes we are getting in that
building boys we're gonna win I'm on the
side door hold down that main door get
him in I'm up in front I'm up in front
let's go
oh he almost got a car in here this is
so chaotic is it a bad idea for me to
just stand here yes yes okay they're
coming they're coming in the front
coming in coming in
help us out Jimmy clear the road sharp
shot and Rolex don't walk in front of me
oh snap you walked in front of me all
right everyone move out the way drag out
watch out watch out stay back on the
door stay back from the doors oh yeah
they're getting obliterated
oh and down
oh my God there's one inside there's one
inside Sheriff we gotta get out of here
uh out here at the back back door about
a shotgun ammo how does that happen
server give them some rocket launchers
or something
all right grenades out RPG
here we go oh I'm getting low I have
less than half my health left all right
let's push out to the vehicles let's go
all right get me out of here server turn
on my spoof
I've only spoof for the next minute go
go go
we made a mistake
get it in get me out of here just drive
I got you I got you let's go
I'm going down quick going down quick
there's two more right here guys there's
two more right here we have to kill them
that's it yeah I'm gonna die there's no
carb
got him we got one more Sheriff's down
no assassins I'm not even at the bank
anymore what are you doing you're
wasting time oh no where is he at
everyone get in the green circle and
heal hurry hurry hurry all right we're
in all right we're healing up wait he's
getting healed where is he he's outside
the fbic
building let's go get him go go go let's
get Jimmy out of here he's gonna survive
let's go sheepdog hey please tell me you
have a game plan where are we going hand
we're right here in the construction
site we're gonna hold him up okay I'm
glad you know this game I want you to go
up top of these stairs Let's Get The
High Ground we'll rain fire on him
follow me we need to just hold it down
here we gotta buy time
okay my decoy wore off I'm now look like
me wait there's only three cops where's
everyone else I don't have a car we need
you bro the only thing standing between
me and death is you three I trust my
life in you you can count on us we got
you man you should go back to securing
the perimeter okay let's go
[Music]
okay heading there now heading there now
I'm just gonna shoot out everything I
see light them up Jimmy we need that
machine gun to sing guys we have to get
up there we have to get up there
they're coming up they're on the ladders
they're up they're up they're up
oh God hold the ladders
oh they're on the crane over there
they're in the crane they're on the
crane right now this might not be a good
spot oh should we go up another layer
follow me Jimmy going up going up one
where is he where's the oh I see him I'm
climbing I'm taking heavy fires
oh my God he's being sprayed oh gosh oh
god oh gosh my health is depleting I'm
taking heavy damage I'm at 500. I'm dead
we only have 10 minutes left I believe
in all of you guys there's only 10
minutes left go go go move move let's go
let's go let's go
I know on the top floor I don't know how
much longer I can hold out where is
everyone
I'm here guys
so dead yeah I'm shooting Darien I'm on
Darion
the numbers are getting low I only have
like five percent of my health left it's
not looking good boys dude Jimmy's about
to die it's very close very close push
push we have seven minutes sheep head
are we gonna live for seven minutes you
will survive my friends they're pushing
in don't worry you're gonna live Jimmy a
couple more hits almost got him someone
kill him please we're getting overrun
six minutes I see him oh he's going down
he's going down
be a car someone help me
no oh no we won let's go
let's go assassins you each just
officially won a thousand dollars I'm
not quite sure how I'll send it to you I
don't really think this through but
congratulations subscribe